[Music]
what you up to I am setting up our
workstation we are gonna paint together
we've been wanting to do like sip and
paint kind of thing prolong paints it
which one is it I don't know I also
smell the oven on yes I am also
preheating the oven for some lunch with
DiGiorno so painting some sipping and
some pizza in furniture is protected
some cheese duct
did you call that the edited my brain is
just ready for this pizza to get in my
body I'm down
[Music]
see you in ten minutes for 12 minutes
making it through 18 to 20 minutes see
you 20 minutes that timer for 18 minutes
18 minutes starting now I personally
like eating pizza with wine I like
pairing those two together is it
elevates the pizza to another level
and I like to think that extra fancy
with the won an extra romantic with the
line and I now we're painting so better
than delivery
are we ready
[Music]
all right there we go
thanks for you Amane thank you so much
that's our work station it is complete
we may begin do that whoo that cheese a
stuffed crust with mouth-watering cheese
guys this is literally my favorite the
perfect balance of like cheese and
toppings of every bite Cheers
I love wine my future the wine and the
cheese is such a good like bounce off
each other all right so what are we
painting we're gonna be painting this
guide I found it on Pinterest so sorry
if you're the original artists I don't
know how
painting a painting works in terms of
like copyright stuff I don't know oh
we're not copying but it's the
inspiration we'll move this guy over
here oh they're just signature at the
bottom if you guys can make that out
credits to that artists props because I
love beach and tropical and everything
with that and it just seems like pretty
romantic and that's kind of the vibe I'm
going for in our bedroom so I thought
how about our very because this is
actually my very first time I'm painting
anything period like after preschool
like I literally never really did
anything ever and you actually studied
arts so you very experienced in the
realm of painting I have just made me
really nervous
why no I got to do a good job Roy what
do I do what does that mean there's any
better turnout amazing no I mean that
you know what you're doing uh-huh thank
you I trust your expertise we're gonna
have fun we're gonna be painting this
we're gonna make some colors and we're
gonna be team working this you know a
first for me actually is painting the
same painting with another person I've
never done that before so this is gonna
be interesting
mm-hmm that's all you got a small canvas
because
is our first time so it's not gonna be a
huge thing if we mess up true if this
goes well we'll go for a bigger canvas
and then we'll like part are our own
artwork all over the house have with
that this goes well could you been
wanting to paint I have actually five a
lot of this paint especially the big tub
back there
I bought that like I don't know like six
months ago because I was like I wanna
paint honey I need to get back into
something that's like just like art that
was such a big part of my life before so
I thought I would have time but I didn't
have time and so oh thanks yeah you get
to paint with me let's sit down to
probably make this thing happen
especially if the city is a gloomy day
um it just kind of feels like this is a
this is a perfect time work it's a
Sunday so you know we have the house to
ourselves it's a gloomy Sunday so it's
like hey how about we create something
together and we can make it nice and fun
with like sip in and paint in and dujour
knowing all that good fun I like it all
right so what are you got we got we need
blue for sure you want to like do a sky
first we should definitely like draw
lines mm-hmm yeah we ever know where to
cut off this for like this die and then
the cut off is between like the beach
and like the ocean water Oh Cheers
water to wash up to breakfast don't
mistake the water for the wine so I'm
gonna take the wife with a lawyer
mm-hmm so we decided to paint so far all
we've been doing is opening paint here
we go get it
I got a winner why is it so hard
air sky-blue you do it all right yeah
well I want to do a straight line it's
scary
this is nice right okay I can't draw
straight lines I'm like okay then I
should've just done it
bizarre oh my gosh my brush is touching
the canvas
[Music]
too much of a perfectionist to really do
this rose I'm like well we gotta do the
whole edges now and then like like it
needs to be like a little bit of this
over there a little bit of that
[Music]
next part we take your already dirty
paintbrush going already great yep
already dirty don't paint it and stand
this into the white that and then I'm
out of clouds deal it's literally not my
thoughts I go you just we just go you do
[Music]
well is it some kind of cheese it is
cottage cheese it's okay well that's a
cool style of basra bri-bri inventing
clowns like these clouds
[Music]
yeah I'm getting a little scared
unless Karen the canvas woo I know it's
had to you know like these are like
waves crashing you have to add the white
oh yeah you deaf and away that looks
like a beach to me
[Music]
and looks really good on camera
I'm so proud of us I am really better
than you yeah oh we got a red our names
gonna sign it signing should we say
anyone it's dry like with the marker
sure we have a pencil what is it what no
okay yeah yeah and then let us know
we'll start a bidding price at like what
like 10 cents
what what's starting
well it's you valuing well I know that
the man is there so like I know it's
gonna be driven up right guys fine all
right
what was the starting price I mean I
would like to value with a little higher
and the starting price is priceless
Oh priceless okay I am so proud of this
and I can't wait to hang it in our room
cuz it totally matches the whole room
aesthetic and yeah and then we get to
sign it at the bottom hopefully this
video was enjoyable for you guys I am
starting to slur my words a little bit
cuz I did a little bit
[Music]
[Music]